Barack Obama claims credit for president
Trump's booming economy Bernie Sanders
loses his mic to topless vegans at a
campaign rally and Mike Bloomberg
intends to win the presidency by telling
Americans have stupid they are then a
democratic Alabama Legislature
introduces a bill that would require men
to get vasectomies we will examine why
I'm skipping Birmingham on this
semester's campus speaking tour all that
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today but first we've
got to thank our friends over at
NetSuite what do companies like ring and
to Kovas have in common you know about
ring you know about to Kovas because
they both advertise on this show those
companies use NetSuite to accelerate
their growth how is that for synergy
that's pretty amazing different
advertisers working together successful
companies know that in order to grow
faster you must have the right tools
that's probably why because successful
companies advertise on our show with
NetSuite you get a full picture of your
business finance inventory HR customers
and more it's everything you need to
grow all in one place right from your
phone or computer
NetSuite will give you the visibility
and control you need to make the right
decisions and grow with confidence this
is one of the big things that grow wrong
companies need is to know their numbers
and NetSuite will let you do it that's
why NetSuite customers grow faster than
the S&P 500
unbelievable NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system right
now schedule your free product tour and
receive your free guides seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles NetSuite
comm slash Knowles that is NetSuite
dot-com slash Knowles Barack Obama
claiming credit for president Trump's
economy to prepare for today's show I
spent some time watching old videos of
Barack Obama reading old stories about
Barack Obama I actually forgot what a
terrible President Obama was and I bet
you did too you've got to go back and
just we're in such a different moment
right now where we've got this energetic
president we've got him pushing
conservative policies we've got him
being uncommonly honest with the
American people for better or for worse
he's saying things and he's actually
doing those things and a great example
of this would be the embassy in
Jerusalem every president for my
lifetime his promise to follow American
policy move the embassy in his real to
Jerusalem no one doesn't own expect him
to do it
Trump comes in because he's such a
political novice he actually does it
people are shocked by that Barack Obama
exactly the opposite he doesn't do what
he says he's going to do
speaks in these mealy-mouthed words he
flops he fails and then he tries to take
credit for other people's success so
here's the tweet that Obama sent down
quote 11 years ago today near the bottom
of the worst recession in generations
I signed the Recovery Act paving the way
for more than a decade of economic
growth in the longest streak of job
creation in American history so it's all
thanks to Obama triad Trump guy didn't
do anything he's just riding on Obama
success right wrong the historical
record is pretty clear and Obama flopped
on the economy what did Obama do 2009
comes around he signs the American
Recovery and Reinvestment Act of 2009
that was supposed to provide a little
under eight hundred billion dollars in
stimulus so-called stimulus money it of
course ran over budget so the total was
831 billion dollars and we were supposed
to get shovel-ready jobs as a result of
this stimulus package except the
shovel-ready jobs didn't materialize
they didn't come for the first two years
of Obama's presidency the unemployment
rate was about 10 percent 10 percent
it's hard for us to imagine that now to
even remember our recent past because we
now have basically no unemployment were
now at record lows of unemployment but
it remained at about 10 percent for the
first two years under Obama the rate
finally began to tick down but that
doesn't even tell the whole story
because part of the reason that the rate
ticked down is because Americans just
gave up looking for work so as the rate
was ticking down after 2010-2011 it
started to go down a little bit
that was because 8 million Americans who
could have been working we're not
working and to be fair to Barack Obama
that that number was going down already
so there were people who were leaving
the workforce anyway and that was
expected to continue but they were only
expecting an additional 3 million
Americans to leave the work force so you
had about 5 million Americans who were
of working age who should have been
working who analysts predicted would be
working under a good economy they were
gone 5 million people in a prime of
their life who should have been working
gone so the unemployment rate
sure but that didn't even tell the story
at the same time wages flatlined
so people who you would hope would be
making a little bit more money were not
at the same time 300,000 manufacturing
jobs disappeared it was actually a
little more than 300,000 manufacturing
jobs gone sent overseas or automated out
of existence or just disappeared because
of the bad economy now Barack Obama what
he tried to do is say look this is the
result of inevitable technological
change and there's just nothing we can
do about it those jobs are just gonna go
away as late as 2016 so don't don't
labor under the misimpression that this
was in those debt terrible days of the
recession and they didn't know what was
happening
this was his latest 2016 the year the
President Trump was elected Barack Obama
said the manufacturing jobs a lot of
them just aren't gonna come back and
there's nothing we can do about it at a
town hall in June of that year he was
asked by an Indiana steel worker what
happened to all the jobs and the answer
he gave was to just throw up his hands
are you doing mr. president
my name is Eric cotton and I'm
representing a Steel Workers Union No Go
1999 I'm trying to find out what do we
have left for ISM all of our jobs are
leaving some of those jobs of the past
are just not going to come back and when
somebody says like the person you just
mentioned who I'm not going to advertise
for that he's going to bring all these
jobs back well how exactly are you going
to do that what are you going to do
there's there's no answer to it he just
says well I'm gonna I'm gonna go she ate
a better deal well ha what how exactly
are you going to negotiate that what
magic wand do you have and usually the
answer is you doesn't have an answer
what magic wand do you have how you
gonna bring those jobs back I don't know
if you had a magic wand but he did bring
the jobs back in the first two years of
Donald Trump's administration more than
six times as many manufacturing jobs
were created as were created during the
last two years of the Obama
administration this was Barack Obama's
big mistake this was his fatal flaw
he was a pretty good rhetorician meaning
he was pretty good at using
slick-talking points to kind of get
around his his bad legacy and his bad
record but he took it a little bit too
far so the this big recession allowed
barack obama to make excuses all we ever
heard for years and years was this was
the worst recession since the Great
Depression we pulled the country back
from the brink this country was heading
off the cliff and we pulled it back from
the cliff republicans drove this country
but their feet on the accelerator
driving right off the cliff right
he just kept blaming everything on the
economy that he inherited from george w
bush but he made this one fatal error
which was that he made predictions and
one of those predictions as the
manufacturing jobs aren't coming back
like he just told that indiana steel
worker except they did come back and so
when the predictions are proven wrong
then you begin to see that his grasp of
the economy isn't so great the best case
that barack obama could make for his
administration's handling of the economy
was that he quote saved us from a Great
Depression that's what you heard all of
his defenders say to the trouble is
that's an unfulfilled is that achill
right there's no way for me to prove or
disprove that Barack Obama saved us from
a Great Depression because the Great
Depression didn't happen and so he got a
lot of credit for these unfalsifiable
claims about what would have happened if
Barack Obama hadn't come along
you can falsify however his predictions
and we did falsify his predictions and
as a result of that because he was wrong
about such a key aspect of his economic
policy we begin to realize that his
entire economic policy was that week we
begin to realize that the claims he's
making that are hypothetical about
saving us from a Great Depression
there's no evidence for that either
President Trump responded to this
yesterday because of course he did you
think there was gonna be a tweet
claiming credit for what he has done a
tweet from a former president that Trump
is not going to respond to of course he
did in his response was really really
really politically shrewd some people
don't want to give him credit for it but
it was a really great response we'll get
to that in a sec
first I've got to thank our friends over
at ring when I'm on the road and I'm on
the road a fair bit
I feel really glad that sweet little
ELISA can rely on ring sure she's a good
shot that's fine but you don't want to
just rely on that rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer now you already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere including little old
me ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world that means
whether you're in your bedroom and you
want to talk and see someone at the
front door or whether you're at the
office or whether you're on a beach
somewhere if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor or a burglar you
will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone as a subscriber you have a special
offer on a ring welcome kit available
right now
ring calm / anoles what's that come with
video doorbell and a chime Pro which is
just what you need to start building a
ring of security around your home go to
ring comm / Knolls kena wles that is
ring comm / Knolls
obama makes this claim tries to take
credit for the Trump economy president
Trump responds here's what he says quote
did you hear the latest con job
President Obama is now trying to take
credit for the economic boom taking
place under the Trump administration he
had the weakest recovery since the Great
Depression
despite 0 Fed rate and massive
quantitative easing so there were low
interest rates and the government was
printing money now best jobs numbers
ever had to rebuild our military which
was totally depleted Fed rate up taxes
and regulations way down if Dems won in
2016 the USA would be in big economic
depression and military trouble right
now the all-caps the best is yet to come
keep America great now it's it's hard to
hear that because it's written in this
kind of crazy-looking syntax but it's
that second third to last line here
which is the key it's this hypothetical
if Dems won in 2016 now if you read it
without the parentheses he says if Dems
won in 2016 the USA would be in big
economic and military trouble right now
but then right after economic he puts in
parentheses to
pression what he's doing is inverting
the Obama hypothetical strategy because
Obama's only claim for his legacy is I
saved us from a Great Depression which
you can't prove or disprove because it's
hypothetical what Trump is doing is he's
going right at that legacy claim and
saying if the Democrats had won in 2016
we might have a depression would we I
don't know it's it's in quick it's a
question thank goodness we didn't have
to find out though if Obama hadn't won
in 2008 would we have gone into
oppression gosh I don't know we're like
let Obama won Trump is using the exact
same thing going right at their only
claim it's really smart
lest you accused me of saying the
president is playing for D Jessie er I
don't know what dimension of chess he is
playing but I do know that he's very
good at PR he's very good at playing the
media he sees the tactic that the
Democrats are using and he just clobbers
it right back on top of them really
smart response and and it's not going
unnoticed the mainstream media are
noticing the economic boom even the
mainstream media even the network's even
ABC News and so Martha Raddatz on ABC
just had Tom Styer who I guess is
running for president he's that
billionaire climate change guy who for
some reason is still in the democratic
debate stages he goes on the show and is
asked about this Martha Raddatz says 70%
of Americans think the economy is doing
well how are you going to convince them
that it's not just are you say that you
can take on Donald Trump on the economy
but the latest Quinnipiac national poll
again released just this week says 70%
of voters described the nation's economy
as excellent or good so how do you
convince them that a change is needed
when they think they're doing so well
under Donald Trump I think if you take a
look at what he says everything he says
superficially sounds right but is
actually a lie so when he says the
economy is growing I can show that in
fact all the money's going to rich
people but I want to go back to that 70
percent number you talk about the
wealthy they're not all wealthy people
seventy percent say the economy is good
and they're doing well well I'm just
saying here we are on a show and you're
standing up
for mr. Trump's version of the economy
and I'm telling you I'm telling you
about a national poll I'm not standing
up for anybody I'm tired I'm telling you
about a national poll you know every so
often these news networks get one bit of
unbiased journalism out there and surely
that's what we just saw from Martha
Raddatz that we actually had to edit out
the awkward pause at this because we
don't have time but she asks him these
questions she says what are you gonna
say to that I mean 70% of Americans
those aren't just the super-rich at 70%
of people and he just kind of stammers
you uh but but it's bad it's really bad
people know that it's not bad
the polls show it even the mainstream
media want to admit it puts the Dems in
a very bad situation one of those
Democrats who is in a bad situation is
the current leading contender for
president that is Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders was recently at a campaign rally
there's there's I think five or six days
left for the Nevada caucuses actually
it's even even less than I think we're
now down to four days left but Bernie
Sanders is out there giving a campaign
rally and some radical environmental
activist jumps on the stage some of whom
were topless jumps on the stage grabs
his microphone and starts screaming
about milk
[Applause]
I believe in you Bernie but I don't
believe in yogurt or cheese or milk
please Bernie stop this is the pressing
issue of our time that woman was not
topless but there have been some
activists I don't really know what the
relation of being nude to the dairy
industry is but anyway I don't know
there's there's some connection because
they keep doing that or they're just
obviously lunatics and that is certainly
the case with this woman right this
group of activists with the animal
rights Network direct action everywhere
are doing this they're jumping on stage
they're following Bernie Sanders around
they're becoming hysterical over the
cruelty of drinking milk how awful that
is to animals now mind you they're
pretty quiet on the issue of a boy
taking milk from a cow is the gravest
cruelty and evil in the world but
killing an unborn baby that's totally
fine killing a million of them a year no
problem they don't really talk about it
something tells me if they did talk
about it they would very likely be in
support of it the fact that Bernie
Sanders is rallies attracts these kind
of people tells you a lot about the
candidate tells you a lot about the
people who go to the Bernie rallies but
people are saying this is not good for
him he's got to get this under control I
don't think so I think it's exactly the
opposite I think these videos these
incidents these crazy activist moments
actually helped Bernie Sanders and if we
get enough of them he's gonna win the
nomination we'll get to why that is in a
second first let's remember that this is
tax season okay and imagine if somebody
just came up without you knowing and
filed for your tax return and got your
money well that sort of thing can happen
during tax season your personal info
like your name maybe your social
security number they might be emailed
they might be shared more than usual and
criminals know this they have a calendar
and they can steal info from your
devices and sell it on the dark web or
use it to commit identity theft
what you need is life lock the number
one most recognized brand in identity
theft protection life lock monitors uses
of your personal info a little earth
shoe for suspicious activity and if you
become a victim of identity theft it's
dedicated identity restoration
specialists will work to fix it very
important no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but
having life lock means one less thing to
stress about during tax season join
right now save up to 25% off your first
year go to life lock dot-com / Knowles
that is life lock Khan / Knowles kena
wles for 25 percent off I think these
crazy moments help Bernie ok Bernie's
biggest advantage in this race is his
lifelong impotence his lifelong
incompetence he hasn't done anything he
hasn't really shown specific political
power he hasn't passed big legislation
he this is this is why
his career is taking off in his mid to
late 70s why wasn't he a big success
when he was a young man the advantage he
has here is he's cultivated this kind of
hapless grandpa image he's cultivated
this Larry David I don't know what God
they took my microphone what can I do
and it makes him seem harmless but the
idea is that he's peddling or not
harmless this guy in political ideology
is a stone-cold commie thug okay I you
look we've played the clips on this show
many times he has defended Fidel Castro
long after the Cuban Revolution he said
that American opposition to commies in
Cuba made him want to puke and he
defended that thug that that animal
Fidel Castro for his whole life he
defends Venezuela he defends the
dictator of Venezuela right now he
defended some of the worst regimes in
history he defended the Soviet Union he
didn't just defend the Soviet Union he
honeymooned in the Soviet Union
he didn't just honeymoon in the Soviet
Union he said shirtless swilling vodka
singing commie folk songs with the
Rooskies in the Soviet Union this guy
defends stone-cold killer regimes now in
a younger man this would be very
off-putting and a man who seemed virile
and potent and tough this would be very
scary we would reject it outright but
because bernie is this sort of lovable
old coot or at least he looks that way
it helps him it helps to mainstream his
ideas all right if it were a young guy
cheering on bread lines bread lines are
actually good direct quote if he if he
were a guy who seemed dangerous to us we
would reject it but because he seems
helpless it's going to allow those ideas
to go on that's why Bernie Sanders
should be praying that more people steal
his microphone it softens him and it
like provides the sugar that will coat
the poison that they're trying to shove
down the throats of Americans now we
also have to get to the other old rich
guy in the way Democratic race I'm
talking of course of Mike Bloomberg and
I hate to do it I have to
sort of defend Mike Bloomberg a little
bit I'll attack him in a second but I
have to I have to sort of defend them
because I think there's some unfair
attacks against Mike Bloomberg in that
people are calling him a racist or a
bigot or some evil guy I don't think
that's the case there are plenty of good
reasons to attack Mike Bloomberg which
we'll get to in a second his presidency
if it ever occurred heaven forfend would
be terrible but I don't think the guys
are racial bigoted so there's more
footage his service to Mike Bloomberg
saying very unpeaceful ears ago that's
come up black and Latino males age let's
say 16 to 25 that don't have jobs don't
have any prospects don't know how to
find jobs don't know that they what
their skill sets are don't know how to
behave in the workplace with a chef's
table we're letting affiliate all right
so this clip which was taken a little
bit out of context but it's from an
interview he gave years ago where
Bloomberg describes people who were more
at risk of committing crime in the same
interview he went on to say a lot of
statistics show that if the father is
engaged it gives the kids some
understanding that he's heading down the
wrong path and then assigned mentors to
them on one on one basis so that there
is somebody who has been successful has
a job has a family fits in society and
that they can go to you know a lot of
these kids it isn't that they're bad
kids it's that once they've made a
mistake it's very difficult to recover
from that but we have an obligation to
them if not for compassionate reasons
just for selfish reasons three-quarters
of all kids in New York City that go to
jail
serve a period and come out go right
back to the jail Bloomberg's critics
especially on the on the left I think
these clips are all being leaked by
left-wing Democratic campaigns they're
saying that this is evidence of bloomers
racism that is not racism it just isn't
I mean racism doesn't have to be this
subjective thing that's based on our
feelings there are objective measures
right is he talking about race is he
making his categorical statements about
race that are discriminatory and
demeaning and no he's not saying that
all black and Hispanic people are
destined to a future of violence and
failure doesn't
at all he's not making any categorical
claims about people on the basis of
their race if we're talking about his
categories he's talking also about sex
he's talking also that age he's talking
also about family structure right
specifically the age comments show that
he's not making a racist or a sexist
argument if he's saying young young
people in this demographic from the age
of 18 to 25 are very likely to commit
crime but not people at age 26 the
people at age 26 are the same races the
people at age 25 so what he's saying is
there are a lot of factors here Mike
Bloomberg would be a terrible president
so it really pains me to defend him in
any way he would be a terrible president
and there are many reasons to attack him
for one he hates the Constitution and he
gaslights people who defend the
Constitution Mike Bloomberg when he was
mayor and after he was mayor started an
organization called Mayors Against
Illegal Guns and this was his anti
second amendment group and he wants to
get rid of the second amendment we
called it Mayors Against Illegal Guns
let me ask you a question how many
mayor's support illegal guns where's the
group that's mayor's for illegal guns
nobodies for illegal guns but he knew
that if he if he actually named the
group what he wanted to which is Mayors
against guns he would be rightly accused
of opposing our Constitution which he
does so he had to call it Mayors Against
Illegal Guns totally dishonest on a
related note actually Mike Bloomberg has
no regard for the rule of law so Mike
Bloomberg when he ran for mayor the
first time right after Rudy Giuliani
that remember this was right after 9/11
Giuliani suggested maybe we make a third
term for mayor so that he America's
mayor could get the the city through
that awful experience you know the worst
crisis New York has ever faced probably
and Bloomberg said no absolutely not the
rule of law has to stick no third term
for Giuliani so no extra terms so Mike
Bloomberg wins and then he immediately
adds a third term so Mike Bloomberg adds
a third term and then immediately after
he wins the third term says we got to
get rid of the third term again he's
just flagrant flagrantly violating the
law
or changing the law to suit his own
preferences he's also a nanny state
liberal who wants to take away even the
most trivial choices from people so you
saw this especially in soda and
cigarettes he wouldn't let you smoke
anywhere wouldn't even let you smoke in
the parks and he made it illegal to buy
big gulps at 7-eleven you couldn't buy a
large cup of Mountain Dew you could buy
two small cups of Mountain Dew but not
one large one
I'm not saying cigarettes are good I'm
not saying big dopes are good I'm saying
that these kind of indulgences are a
small comfort and consolation to people
they kind of like them it's not the
biggest deal in the world and yet Mike
Bloomberg went after them he made it a
top priority of his administration in
New York proof of HL Mencken's assertion
that Puritanism is the haunting fear
that someone somewhere might be happy
that's what a Bloomberg presidency would
look like on top of all that Bloomberg
seems to have zero connection to people
okay he wants to tell people what to do
but he doesn't seem to enjoy spending
any time with them and you saw this in
another clip that is actually worth
going after Bloomberg for you know the
clip where they pull up something from
20 years ago and he made some comment
about crime that's not why you should go
after Bloomberg all right I don't think
it's evidence of racial bigotry you
should go after Bloomberg because he
seems not really to respect people you
just saw this come out where he made the
claim that farmers are just a bunch of
idiots anybody even people in this room
so no offense intended to be a farmer
you it's a processor you dig a hole you
put a seed in you put dirt on top add
water up comes the corn then we had 300
you could learn that then then you have
300 years of the industrial society you
put the piece of metal on the lathe you
turn the crank in the direction of the
arrow and you can have a job and we
created a lot of jobs one point 98
percent of the world worked in in
agriculture today it's 2 percent in the
United States now comes the information
economy and the information economy is
fundamentally different because it's
built around replacing people with
technology and the skill sets that you
have to learn are how to think and
analyze and that is a whole degree level
different you have to have a different
skill set you have to have a lot more
gray matter you have to have a lot more
gray matter you know you gotta have a
lot more brains now like those idiot
farmers you've got to be able to think
and analyze you see look what you don't
understand you you plebs you peasants
well you don't understand is that if you
want to be a middle manager in the HR
department of the widget Factory you
need to use these really highly
developed analytical skills but if you
want to make food grow out of the ground
if you want to manage seed oil climate
the the changing weather changing
temperatures if you want to manage all
of that well you don't need a brain you
just you're basically a mule right you
don't need to if you want a farm or if
you want to raise animals right you want
to raise cattle you don't need to
analyze anything you just kind of walk
out every day I think it's with warm
today I hope it grows right that's how
it works right of course it's not of
course it's the opposite of that of
course it requires many many more
analytical skills it requires a lot more
gray matter to make something grow out
of the ground or to raise animals or to
manage the whole economy of Agriculture
than it does to be some pencil pusher
in some random department of the widget
Factory but that is the bias of Mike
Bloomberg because Mike Bloomberg doesn't
have a whole lot of respect for people
doesn't have a whole lot of respect for
his fellow countrymen that's why he's
willing to deprive them of their basic
civil rights under the Constitution like
the Second Amendment and that's why he
mocks farmers is not having a whole lot
of gray matter that's why we should go
after Mike blue
okay those are good arguments for it but
these could taking these kind of cheap
shots from the far left against him on
crime or something I don't think that's
a particularly winning strategy and
we've also got to get to the other
really really old guy in the Democratic
race Joe Biden because he is speaking of
far left ISM he is now running as far to
the left as he possibly can and this is
not winning him left-wingers but this is
turning off a lot of moderates he made a
claim that you hear the left make a lot
about immigration we will examine why
that's just totally bogus then there is
a failed Democratic gubernatorial
candidate who is now going to accept the
vice presidential nomination nobody's
asked her but she's gonna accept it
anyway we'll get to that in a second and
we'll get to why I'm not speaking on
campus in Alabama this year because I
don't want don't want to get a forced
vasectomy we'll get to all of that in a
second first I want to take a moment to
thank some very important people namely
you are daily wire members we get to
make content that matters because of you
and you help us help to keep us on the
front lines of the culture war if you
have been a little on the fence about
joining the daily wire community I want
to bring your attention to a somewhat
overlooked membership tier which is the
readers pass readers pass gets you the
articles ad-free including bench bureaus
op eds which are exclusive for daily
wire members you also get access to our
mobile app which has become very popular
with our members and you can read all of
our stories on mobile and you can also
receive push notifications for breaking
news and special content which is
perfect for when you want to stay up to
date on the go this Membership tier is a
bargain it's only three bucks a month
and if you're still a little unsure
about this listen to this special offer
right now we're gonna offer one month
for just 99 cents you can pull that
Eddie or couch cushions that's mobile ad
free access to all of Daley wire news
exclusive op-eds from Ben Shapiro
breaking news updates on our mobile app
and all for the low price of just a buck
so go check it out you won't be
disappointed ble wire.com we'll be back
with a lot more
we hit Bernie we hit Bloomberg we got to
get to Joe Biden of those three guys Joe
Biden may be saying the most radical
thing of all of them right now
which you wouldn't imagine right you got
this old crazy old communist you got a
guy who as mayor all he wanted to do was
steal people's Second Amendment civil
liberties and steal their sodas and
steal their cigarettes and they got Joe
Biden allegedly the moderate in this
race but he's running so far to the left
now cuz he's flailing he sees the
nomination running away from him it's
not working polls are showing it's not
winning him some massive new left-wing
support it's just killing his support
among the moderates the comment that
Biden made which I find so offensive
both intellectually and nationally
offensive is he said that illegal aliens
who are here who are young they call
them dreamers or daca mind you some of
these guys are in their 40s at this
point but they're still we all are
supposed to imagine these like five year
olds looking up with these big cute eyes
or something and some of these people
are fully grown adults Joe Biden says
the dock dreamers illegal aliens are
more American than many Americans these
doctor students are more Americans than
most Americans are no I'm sure it's
think about it
no I'm serious I think about it they're
not people who are not Americans cannot
be more American than Americans thank
you for coming to my TED talk I hope my
argument isn't convincing let me I'll
take you through it again people who are
not Americans people who do not have the
quality of being American can not be
more American than Americans that's the
whole argument this is one of these dumb
talking points that comes up on the Left
a lot and it they're always of the if
you really think about it variety right
that's what they owe it they'll say
something that's just patently untrue
and absurd and then they'll say but if
you really think about it actually Joe
Biden literally said that right he goes
these daca students are more American
than most Americans I mean think about
it okay well I have thought about it and
that doesn't make any sense
part of what's going on here is because
just on a philosophical level the the
left has lost its grasp of objective
reality because the life now tells us
that men are not really men and women
are not really women and we can't really
know anything and there's your truth and
my truth but know the truth because of
that they will make absurd statements
but if they say them in fatica ly and
repeatedly then they think that that is
enough to make those false statements
true which they're not the other error
they're falling into here is they're
trying to make american-ness something
more than it is somebody responded when
I pointed this out on Twitter they said
oh Michael the question is what does it
mean to be American you know is it just
merely having American citizenship yes
yep there are there are there are things
that are like Americans do or like
Americans are there are certain
qualities that Americans have right grit
determination independence religiosity
right those are all qualities of
Americans but those are not synonymous
with being American the only thing that
makes you an American is being a citizen
of America that's it that's the whole
story there are plenty of non Americans
there are plenty of foreigners plenty of
illegal aliens who are wonderful people
there there are also plenty of Americans
who are rotten no-good people American
is not a synonym for perfect wonderful
there there are qualities that these
things have but American refers to
Americans they want to confuse this
issue because what the left really wants
to say is there's no such thing as
citizenship citizenship doesn't mean
anything that's why they use these they
went from illegal alien which is the
precise term to illegal immigrant to
undocumented immigrant to future
American as though the only distinction
between Americans and non-americans is
some documents no it's whether it's a
specific document namely if you were a
citizen or not the only difference
between illegal aliens and Americans is
Americans are current Americans and
illegal aliens are future Americans no
they're not entitled to American
citizenship just like I'm not entitled
to Danish citizenship or Chinese
citizenship I'm not a future Chinese
person I'm an American I'm something
different okay this substitution of
American for just goodness is very
tempting to conservatives because we
love our country and we know that we
have a very good country we should not
fall into that we got to be very very
precise about our language because the
way that the Left wins the culture I've
talked about this ad nauseam I did a
Praeger video on it I've done speeches
on it I'm writing a book on it the way
that the Left wins the culture is by
using vague language using tempting
language intoxicating language American
yeah merica just means good and and some
of these illegal aliens are good no be
very specific because what they would
have us do by using that kind of vague
tempting language is totally subvert the
country undermine any kind of American
identity I mean what they're saying is
that a country has nothing to do with
the people of that country they've
already said that country has nothing to
do with borders right they want to get
rid of borders they say this is stolen
land occupied land it's not legitimate
but now they're saying that even the
people of the country have nothing to do
with the country in other words if you
have any million Americans 320 million
just about that if you took all 320
million Americans removed them from the
country and then replaced them with
foreigners who share these abstract
vague qualities of american-ness that
you would have the same country no
country in the history of the world has
ever believed that in America I has
never believed that and I don't think
America believes that currently which is
why he'd show Biden is collapsing and
why the flailing is only getting worse
gotta pay attention to that though
because when the Democrats when the left
has no mooring in that objective reality
when they're just putting up these kind
of spineless flattering oily politicians
like Joe Biden then all of a sudden the
most moderate guy in the race all of a
sudden can become one of the most
radical speaking of radical Democratic
candidates speaking of having no regard
for true
Stacey Abrams failed candidate for
governor of Georgia has accepted the
vice presidential nomination in 2020
she hasn't been offered it but she's
accepted it for those of you who don't
remember Stacey Abrams which I suspect
is most of you Stacey Abrams ran for
governor of Georgia in 2018 and she lost
then she claimed without any evidence
whatsoever that the election was stolen
now she goes on TV as if she won the
election so it is no surprise that in a
recent appearance on the view Abrams
said that she would accept
vice-presidential nomination which she
of course has not received the first
time I was on here I got the question
about running as VP during the primary
and I very apparently famously said no
because you don't run for a second in a
primary right however because that
conversation started I'm now getting the
question a lot from folks and the answer
is of course I would be honored to run
for vice president with the nominee and
it's a bit disconcerting because it
seems really obnoxious for me to say
that out loud
since I'm not you know was asked me but
what I want people to understand is that
in the media yeah exactly the the issue
is as a woman of color especially as a
black woman this is an unusual position
to be in for someone to be considered
possibly the next vice president this is
a very unusual position it's just
unimaginable that anyone would say that
a woman or a person of color or a black
person could ever be the vice president
right I mean it's certainly not the
president there's no except the very
last Democratic nominee for president
was a woman and the a couple times ago
the vice presidential nominee for the
Republicans was a woman and the last
president himself the very last
president was a black guy this isn't
unimaginable at all this is very
imaginable this is eminently imaginable
this has become routine as a matter of
fact what is unimaginable is that
somebody who is a virtual unknown in
American politics who ran it for a race
enjoy
and lost would then try to fail upward
by elevating herself to become the vice
president that is unimaginable Stacey
Abrams is doing this thing that
Democrats keep doing they can't you see
it all the way back to Barack Obama
trying to take credit for the economy
they can't point to their own
accomplishments they can't point to
anything concrete they've done so they
just fall into Imaginationland I wonder
if this is a result of the self-esteem
movement I wonder if this is a result of
participation trophies that that these
candidates these politicians just cannot
fathom that they lost that they failed
that they didn't do something it's not
possible they have to get the trophy
even if President Trump won the trophy
on his economy even if your opponent in
the Georgia governor election won you
got to take the trophy yourself you have
to win as well but that isn't the case
and nobody believes people see Obama
trying to take credit for Trump's
economy they laugh sure there are some
hard partisans who buy anything that
they say but most people I think they
kind of laugh about it most people when
they see this failed governor candidate
go on television and say okay I will be
the vice president they laugh about this
who are you you lost bait or work lost a
Senate race then he thought he could run
for president cuz it's not possible for
the Democrats to lose it's not reality
is not binding on Democrats reality is
not binding on the left except
eventually it is this is the great
conservative consolation Russell Kirk
who wrote a great book the conservative
mind said that one of the great
conservative consolations is that
reality eventually reasserts itself and
so you can go off and fantasy for a
little while but eventually reality
comes crashing down it's one of the
reasons why conservatives don't get
totally routed that one initially that
book was gonna be called the
conservative route the conservative just
keep losing everything except every so
often they come back because reality
reasserts itself in the end it's
reasserting itself stacey abrams
researching cell phone joe biden that's
reasserting
self on Barack Obama and I can't wait
until reality reasserts itself in
Alabama I actually speaking of the view
there you see another clip of on the
same topic from Joy Behar on the view
there is a new bill in Alabama in the
Alabama Legislature that would require
men to get vasectomies this is seriously
making me rethink my plans to retire to
Mobile Alabama someday Mobile is my
favorite town in the country and now
it's looking a little less appealing
effect if that law goes through state
representative Rolanda Hillis Democrat
from Birmingham filed a bill last
Thursday that would mandate every
Alabama man to undergo a vasectomy
snip-snip within one month of his 50th
birthday or the birth of his third
biological child whichever comes first
no one's allowed to these Democrats
really really don't like babies you
noticed that they they want to get them
in the womb they want to get them before
the womb they want to get them a new
third kid this this is HB 314 that this
this woman is responding to and HB 314
is the human life Protection Act so this
is basically to say you can't kill
babies in the womb now this woman is
going to respond and say okay well men
have to get vasectomy as she says under
existing law there are no restrictions
on the reproductive rights of men and
you know we've heard this before from
the left we hear it all the time Joy
Behar on the view made the same dumb
point
yeah panel of men who did this now that
Mary knows yeah what is it G what do
they have in common well I think they
were all ramen or white guys not here
they are oh my god
maybe it should make them a law that
they should all be required to get a
vasectomy that group
yeah whoo how clever how you got her you
got him how funny I've never heard that
of course that totally avoids the issue
conservatives don't want to avoid the
issue the left does want to avoid the
issue what's the issue when we're
talking about abortion which is what
this whole thing is about they're not
really going to mandate best ectomy is
in Alabama we're talking about abortion
what's the question is the baby a baby
should we be allowed to kill the baby or
a million babies a year without any
legal protection that's the question it
would seem that the evidence that the
baby is a baby is pretty strong
the baby's human nobody suggests the
baby is not human the baby is alive
nobody suggests the baby is dead as a
miscarriage or an abortion right the
point of an abortion is to take the baby
from alive to dead the baby if left
alone will grow up to be a toddler and
then an adult and then an old person is
a human life and so we're saying you
shouldn't kill that has nothing to do
with the reproductive rights of women
saying mothers shouldn't be able to kill
their kids the left wants to avoid that
issue and say they're just trying to
control women's ovaries no we don't I
don't care about women's ovaries I care
about if we're killing babies yeah we're
gonna give you a vasectomies totally
misses the point conservatives like to
talk about the issue the left wants to
avoid the issue not just on this issue
but on many issues that's why by the way
conservatives are always arguing with
ourselves you'll notice they're all they
always these fights on the right all
these different segments of the right
the libertarians versus the
traditionalists versus the neo cons
versus the religious right versus right
there you could go on and on and on
between all these segments they're
always arguing about each other trying
to get to the heart of the issue that
doesn't happen on the left on the left
there is just progressivism there are
the progressives and and also the
progressives
that's it the left can't argue with
itself is the for many reasons but the
left can't form these arguments the left
doesn't doesn't understand what
arguments are being made and the left
most importantly is it divorced itself
from objective reality so the left is
saying there is no truth there it's your
truth and his truth but not the truth
the left is saying that you can't say
that a man as a man or a woman as a
woman it's all very
it's all just a bunch of different
interest groups and so it I mean it's
literally if you accept that premise
it's not capable of argument that's why
the left goes off the rails that's why
the right reigns itself in through that
kind of argumentation that's why you see
the left came claiming credit for things
that never did accepting vice
presidential nominations that it never
got making claims that are just
philosophically impossible that's why
you see it spinning off into absurdity
that's why you see the right grounded in
reality now absurdity and fantasy wins
for a while but the reality reasserts
itself in the end and that's a nice
consolation for those of us who are
right and who are on the right that's
our show on Michael noses the Michael
Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talk and
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you